i ragazzi questo non video sono falli
genoa ci sono quattro sfruttare i miei
amici per fare le blues erano un po che
non facevo già sensi in coppia con
qualcuno e visto che sono sempre molto
poco eterosessuale in certi ambienti
facciamo che farlo con un amico invece
con una bella [ __ ]
puoi fare la mia mano già pazza cammino
per gli che avevo con quella fascetta ma
sei sicuro di tenermi testa in questa
qua lato bello è un ballo molto molto
sessuale questo ragazzo un secondo chi
stiamo dando il meglio di noi questo
bene jean de a una domanda così una
faccia di me la faccia da cane bastonato
non voglio fare ma è una vecchia che non
ti voglio bene
sì ma danno che cazzo vengo illumino
ecco che compare lino cambiano
dimenticati tutto bello bravissimo da
lei concreto di quanto la frasetta di
fare questo padre vero l'intero 20 poi
con l'originalità per altro figlio poco
se non che cementano sembra visionale al
grazie amico migliore
perché milan e soddisfazione degli
mentre facevo il video che hanno alla
fine
una stella mi hanno messo dentro della
gente per fare il suo padre vita a me
senza teste ricordiamo tutti come quando
tocchi le verifiche le confida uno che
prende due uguali come che si è spostato
per corti rete perché la tecnica tutta
eccitata dicevo al culetto lenti ma ero
troppo bravo e ridi che ti guarda te il
giorno la causa civile per tutto questo
dietro miliardi sono capace di non far
mai agenti fatte bene o finto se sei
mezzo per la grazia o meno web
finché sono arrivato sia freeman che
secondo è noi in totale ho preso tre
stelle di due più ma per me la vedi come
ero convinto nei miei pensieri
fateci vedere nero era allenatissimo
orari va bene che ti dolore dice della
canzone scegli quello che vuoi
non ci interessa è uscita addetti e
trovando la canzone che ho fatto io
adesso su canti la canzone con me se non
lo sai non sei mio amico bello ci siamo
ragazzi siete pronti non mi vieni a
tutti
bene le cose e inseguire quel bambino
anche 4 2 con ci sono i reggini
vedo la gente come viscontini
si fanno i sensi io non so più che farmi
chiude in camera ne possono più lo sai
non lo sei mio amico sul tuo amico non
segue i corsi non ne posso più è la
calma e cosa c'è di più
che cosa c'è di un po che cosa scelta
non lo sapete siete chiesti i marroni
finirà così scuse lui e sbaglio è
sbagliato non guardo quelle mia farrow
fra fermarmi di piedi e ci smart in
pieno e cioè ma come ben dice per
qualche pioggia c'è e c'è un'armonia di
fff si scontrano caccia vicenda di ore
ti voglio bene
arriverà uno di quei tanto bene tu io
sto facendo schifo la canzone mica sono
troppo alla canzone mia non ci siamo
nemmeno ci davano 20 prima tematiche e
32 minuto io non faccio un paio spaccio
ballerino that day questo di rimane così
a persona cosa è sempre e poi usati per
rimorchiare bara che bella faccia che
ciò è superata l'ultima perché bravo
questo la faccia bella è sembrata
l'ultimo caso è vero era la mia io può
finire qua che fino a quasi zero
condividere istituita si tango tornan e
non c'è la mia mamma c'è la frutta
attaccato anni pago mia mamma comunque
la piega arriva controlla se sono fuori
ho chiuso
si trovano tutte c'è pieno pieno c'è
tutta la fila ragazza della fiera di
[ __ ] e un attimo ragazze che finiamo il
video è finito l'orario il massimo da
bill haas sweet dreams shift reds scrive
uffici dei e decide lui io non glielo
faccio parte ha reciso la kick him becca
la faccia per prima bello eh siamo una
persona sosta aiuta e questo perché sono
nero la prende perché sono nero è tutto
razzista ecco ecco ciao amici ma bossi
lo diciamo mamma ma sempre chi si voglia
parlare sia nessun timore che rubò tutte
non siamo fessi lion anni ed è grazie a
cazzo ragazze un attimo è che finiamo
con la fiat
due secondi arriviamo finita subito sta
canzone tanto stiamo facendo tutti feste
un amico
la pallina la giornata che migliorerà se
non mi far alzare palloni non passerà
mai di moda e di moda da una ditta
questo propone un ginocchio
conosco bene ha fatto per la [ __ ] dai
pensa io che abbiamo messo dentro gioco
per le mie paure il da ballerino diciamo
che premi tanto se ti sei mangiato cozze
aiutati da un pattern tantissimo pensavo
neanche tu dentro già le jardin se
volete farmi mettere dentro c'è anche
lui che bravo bisogno 4 stelle scarpe
che il miur ha emanato nei cinque che
sentono mai fatto così tanto giorno
incredibile sono quattro stelle quadrati
quanto non l'ho presa rimane così per
sempre così così ragazzi un secondo
arrivo arrivo hai mai vedere che sono
tutte calde paragone ci stiamo guardando
di molto sexy
ubisoft che guarderete questo video per
gli aumenti
noi siamo fatti per te regia io noi
siamo bravi a ballare a fare andare le
cose quindi in un sexy in just dance
2018 mettiamo anche ed andiamo
onore a chi sono ma dai che ti sei
trovato la casa guarda qua ma che merda
avevano subodorato fatto ritenere
sbrodolina coca cola batte sheikh
ma c'è per fare valere le 5 lasciato la
pista per te che tutti sentono tutto e
sono l'acido be bisogno
[Musica]
ora purtroppo le mani ma io sono
fratello due stelle di camion e un
confronto prima si è andati benissimo
rehn
la bella e basta e stato bellissimo
va bene ragazzi io direi che possiamo
concludere che questo episodio
bellissimo di just dance
ringrazio dania comunque ragazzi spero
che questo film sia piaciuto corso e al
momento è un mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e con iscrizione grazie ciao
prossimo video dai ragazzi non si ficca
questo passo